>>Female Commentator: Hi everyone and welcome
to Authors@ Google Ann Arbor.
We are proud to have Steve Lehto here again
with us today. You may remember him from his
recent chat with us about Michigan's Columbus:
The Life of Douglass Houghton.
Today he's here to present to us and talk
to us about Chrysler's Turbine Car. So forward
written by Jay Leno, and we have the Wall
Street Journal article for all of you to view
as well.
This story takes place in 1964. Chrysler built
a fleet of turbine cars; automobiles with
jet engines and lent them out to the members
of the public. The fleet logged over a million
miles; the exercise was a raging success.
And this is the story.
>>Steve Lehto: Thank you.
Well, if you look at the image on the screen,
this right here is a bunch of guys standing
around a car and the reason that this is a
momentous moment, 1953, is that these gentlemen
are lowering a jet engine into a car.
And many people who've heard of the turbine
car project know that Chrysler and GM and
Ford all experimented with jet engines in
cars for a period of time. But a lot of people
are not aware of the fact that Chrysler actually
spent 25 years developing jet engine technology
in the automotive field, and they actually
got further along than anybody else did.
So this a great occasion and I'll talk to
you some more about some of the people in
this photograph. On the far right is a man
named George Huebner. He was the head of the
turbine car program and a very, very flamboyant
gentleman. I only found one photograph of
him where he's not wearing an expensive suit,
but in this image you'll see that he is.
And then standing next to the car with his
right hand on the fender of the car wearing
a dark suit is a guy named Dr. Sam Williams.
I'll talk some more about him as well.
But like I said they were just here lowering
an engine in a car, this would be 1953.
So they did put the jet engine in the car
and they took it out for a spin and they called
up all the local press and said, "Come on
out. Bring your news cameras, your reporters,
your journalists." And of course that's the
whole host of people you see in the left hand
side of the screen there.
And this is the public unveiling of the first
jet powered car. And it was a huge news event
if you look at the papers from the time; not
just the local papers, but even the national
newspapers like the New York Times or even
like Time Magazine or Look Magazine or Life
Magazine or any of those there'd be stories
about the jet powered cars being built by
Chrysler.
And a lot of people who aren't familiar with
the technology might not know this, but jet
engines offer some big advantages over the
typical piston engine.
A jet engine's got fewer moving parts; it
weighs less; it spins, the internal parts
spin rather than reciprocate, meaning that
pistons go back and forth and cause an engine
to shake or vibrate; a piston engine spins
so therefore it's much smoother.
But the important thing now that we look back
on it and realize is a jet engine will burn
on, run on anything that burns. So you can
run a jet engine on not only on gasoline,
but alcohol, kerosene, diesel, vegetable oil,
peanut oil, Chanel No. 5, vodka, tequila,
VO5 hairspray. They'd actually do demonstrates
running the cars on these things.
But again, during this time frame gasoline
cost so little that very few people cared.
They say, "Well why do we need a cheaper alternative
to gasoline when we've got gasoline?"
So the program gets developed; they start
building these cars and as they're developed-developing
them they're making the engines more and more
efficient.
Here's another one of the cars that has a
turbine engine in it. Many of the early cars
were simply other Chrysler products that they
had shoe-horned a jet engine into.
So again nothing on this car would tell you
it's a jet engine except that it sounded different.
So when this car drove by you it would sound
like a low flying jet.
And I can tell you 'cause I've driven one,
and I'll talk about that in a minute, but
that's-that's the-the main difference to the
average person on the street.
This right here is a picture of George Huebner
and like I said it's the only picture where
he's not wearing a jacket. And the reason
is, and he's the second man from the right,
he was ahead of the turbine car program and
he's the one who came to Chrysler and said,
"I really want to build jet powered cars here,"
and he got them to put up the investment,
let him hire the team. He his whole turbine
department built around this.
During the same time though, Chrysler was
actually known as being the engineering company.
Of the Big Three, Chrysler was best known
as being the innovators in engineering.
They also did stuff with the space program.
So the man standing to Huebner's right with
the ax on his shirt, that's Wernher von Braun.
And those of you who remember the Apollo program,
Wernher von Braun is a German scientist who
came over here after World War II and helped
us put a man on the moon. And Huebner worked
with von Braun on missiles at Chrysler.
Chrysler helped build the missiles for the
Redstone Program and some of the earliest
space stuff was built by Chrysler.
And in case you're curious, Chrysler also
helped build a lot of military stuff; so army
tanks, for instance, Chrysler had built 'em.
So we don't think of them today in the military
sense nor do we think of them in the rocket
sense, but at the time Chrysler was known
cutting edge technology.
So here's George Huebner dressed more appropriately
wearing a nice suit and tie.
He was actually in, it-it's an interesting
thing. He was an extraverted engineer. And
anybody who knows an engineer knows how-how
oxymoronic that is. That he's outgoing, flamboyant,
loved attention and publicity, and he was
an engineer.
In fact after he passed away his, all of his
papers and research were donated to the Bentley
Historical archives which is where I did a
lot of research for this book , so it's right
around the corner here.
But this is George Huebner and any time a
camera was around it seems he got himself
photographed near a turbine powered car.
And so this is a car about 1961 or '62 and
that's a jet engine under the hood and some
of the items that go into a jet engine there,
and I'll talk to you about that in just a
second.
And I'll, yeah, okay.
[pause]
And this is another turbine powered car that
George Huebner is kneeling behind and this
one does say across the decklist it's says
"Turbine Special."
And as Chrysler became more and more confident
that the cars would work they started putting
things on the cars indicating they were in
fact turbine powered.
George, here in this picture, is demonstrating
that the exhaust gases coming out of this
car are not dangerous.
One of the most common misperceptions about
the program was that the jet engines were
dangerous. And I to this day run into people
who say, "Oh I understand they killed that
program because the-the exhaust was so hot
it burned the pavement or catch cars on fire
or kill children."
[chuckle from audience member]
And the-the exhaust was actually cooler than
the exhaust coming out of a typi-typical piston
engine car at the time.
So that's George Huebner holding a handkerchief
by the by the exhaust here to demonstrate
that.
On another occasion he brought out some pretty
young women wearing dresses, skirts, and had
them adjust their nylons in front of the exhaust
pipe to show that it wouldn't burn a woman's
nylons. And of course the photographers ate
it up because they were mostly men and the
women were pretty so.
[audience chuckles]
Here's another Chrysler powered car again,
you know as Turbine Special.
As they got the cars practical they decided
they were gonna start doing endurance stuff
with 'em to show how dependable they were.
So on a couple occasions George Huebner, and
remember this is a guy that's a very, very
high executive at Chrysler, and some of his
co-workers actually drove these cars cross
country.
So they would take a car to like say the New
York Auto Show and have a press event outside
and then the guys all drive off to the sunset,
and a couple thousand miles later they'd have
a press event in Los Angeles where they all
arrive at some hotel and say, "Hey guys were
here. We just drove this thing cross country."
So several of these cars were driven cross
country, and relatively trouble free.
While researching the book not only did I
interview the engineers who designed these
things, I actually designed or interviewed
some of the engineers who drove these things
cross country.
And they were just talking about you just
get on the freeway, just cruisin' along in
a jet powered car and you know it's pretty
cool.
So here's one of the cars in the top that
was driven cross country and you see on the
side there's a map there just in case you
get lost to let you know where in the country
that car has been.
And again Chrysler was doing this. They were
getting a lot of publicity out of this.
And some people have looked back in the program
and said, "Obviously were not driving jet
powered cars today. What did Chrysler get
out of this program if they didn't get jet
powered cars?"
Well they got a lot of free publicity. Well
not free, but it wasn't advertising that they
didn't pay money for.
So anytime these cars would show up some place
the press would show up and then you'd see
these stories splattered all over the papers:
Chrysler Unveils Another Jet Powered Car.
Here's George Huebner on one of his cross
country trips. That's his wife. And these
are obviously publicity photos, but they'd
be leaked to the press as if they were candid
shots. And I can tell you that they're not
candid 'cause among other things again George
is very well dressed. You'll notice he's sticking
his head out the window 'cause he learned
very early on if you don't do that, you don't
show up in the pictures as-as prominently.
And of course you'll notice that he's showing
the intricate workings of the turbine engine
to the bellhop
[laughter]
there on the top right.
And on the bottom right he's discussing the
shape of the contiguous 48 states with some
executives from Chrysler who just happen to
be there when he left.
[laughter]
But again, publicity shots.
And a lot of these photographs were taken
'cause they had publicity guys following these
guys around photographing everything, interviewing
them, and feeding these stories to the press.
So like I said, the program started in 1953.
It ran 'till 1978. So for 25 years there's
a steady supply of this stuff in the press.
So this is an aerial shot looking down on
the engine; one of the jet engines that they
put into a car, a turbine engine.
And you'll notice that in the front those
two things that look like beer kegs. Those
are actually air cleaners.
So for the car guys in the room you know that
an air cleaner normally sits on top of the
engine, but a turbine engine, of course, uses
huge quantities of air as well as pretty large
quantities of fuel.
And a lot of the noise you associate with
a jet engine if you were to go walk along
the tarmac at an airport, the sound you hear,
half of the sound is coming from the front
end where the air is coming into the engine.
And so to quiet these engines down they got
those gigantic air cleaners there and they
figured out if they faced 'em at each other
it would actually kind of cancel out some
of the noise. So in later years they actually
got a housing that went over the whole thing,
but those are just two gigantic air cleaners.
And then directly behind that is the turbine
engine.
They would come up with different generation
turbine engines and they would number them.
So this is a cutaway of the fourth-generation
turbine engine and at this point in time they'd
worked out enough of the problems of the technology
to where they had an engine that was dependable
and was relatively bullet proof.
Because they came up with an idea to promote
the project that they were gonna build a fleet
of cars and lend them to the public.
So that if you were in America in 1963, you'd
hear on the news that Chrysler's building
jet cars and they're willing to lend them
to anybody who wants one. If you want one
write to Chrysler and they might give you
one.
And so they got flooded with requests for
these cars, but to do that obviously Chrysler's
gotta have a car that they can toss a key
to you and say, "Here, go drive this car,"
knowing that the average knucklehead's not
gonna take it out and blow it up.
Because as you can imagine if they were to
do that with like say a Dodge Vipers, let
people drive 'em, half of them would come
back with blown engines, right? So they had
to make the engines bullet proof in that respect.
And so this is the fourth-generation engine
and this is the engine that they decided was
good enough to do that. And it actually was.
So they actually assembled the cars in a plant
on Greenfield Road in Detroit. The plant is
still there although the plant now is being
used to make popcorn, I kid you not.
[laughter]
And the cars in the background, I'll show
you some better pictures in a second, but
the cars were hand built in Italy by a company
called Ghia.
And some of you car guys know this that there's
a Karmann Ghia car that Volkwagen marketed.
Ghia is a builder of they're referred to as
coach builders, but they build the bodies
of cars; they did a lot of show cars for Chrysler.
And the cars in question were often referred
to as the Ghia Turbine Car built in 1963.
They build a fleet of 55 of these cars.
The cars were relatively, for the most part,
hand built. They had aluminum body panels.
They had leather interiors and 54 of the 55
cars were identical: same color, same interior,
same everything, down to the point where even
the same key would start all 55 cars.
[laughter]
So this right here is what the Ghia Turbine
Car looks like in color. That paint is referred
to as Turbine Bronze. Chrysler wanted to come
up with a color that was unique but also seemed
kind of space age.
And if you were in Southeastern Michigan in
particular, but anywhere in America, between
'63 and '66, you would see these cars on the
road from time to time. You couldn't miss
'em because they are an unusual color and
they sounded like jets.
So I was born in 1962. I remember as a very
small child seeing one of these cars and the-the
two things you remember: the color and the
sound.
So this car right here is the one that Jay
Leno owns, and I'll tell you a little bit
about the story in a second.
But that's what all these cars looked like.
The car was designed by a guy named Elwood
Engel. And Elwood Engel had come over to Chrysler's
design studios from Ford. And when he was
at Ford he worked on the Thunderbirds.
So many people look at this and they go, "Hey
it's a T-Bird." Well it's similar 'cause the
same guy designed it. Some people would jokingly
call this the Engel Bird. But it's the Chrysler
Ghia Turbine Car.
And we call it the Turbine Car because it
actually does not have a name. They toyed
with the idea about naming it something. You
don't have cars that don't have names. And
they were gonna call it the Typhoon and they
had some other names they kicked around, but
they decided just to go ahead and just called
it the Turbine Car.
So on the side there next to the gas cap on
the left you'll see the tail end does say
Turbine on the side, but that's all it says.
It doesn't say anything else.
A lot of people like the space age styling
of the car. Everything about the car was designed
to remind you that this is a jet car. So you'll
notice those things stickin' out the back
with the fins on 'em, those are the backup
lights.
But they're designed to look cool. People
always assume you walk over and like feel
hot air coming out of those. No, no, no that's
just backup lights.
And again notice the really unusual sweep
to the back there to evoke like fins and rockets
and so on.
They put those styling touches, those aluminum
fins on everything. The bezels around the
headlights have got cooling fins on them.
The little rod that holds the rearview mirror
to the glass of the windshield has got cooling
fins on it. It doesn't need 'em obviously,
but they did it because they thought it was
cool.
So this is inside one of the cars, and I'll
you little bit more about this car in a second,
but again all the cars looked identical on
the inside.
And if you just glance at this, at first glance
you think, "Well that looks like any other
car from the 1960's." Except that the right
hand side is a tachometer which goes to 60,000
RPM. Your average car today goes to about
6,000 RPM. But of course a turbine engine
spins very, very fast so the tachometer is
a 60,000 RPM.
The temperature gauge goes to 2,000 degrees,
whereas the temperature gauge in your car
might go to 200.
But again it's measuring something different.
The temperature gauge in your car measures
the coolant temperature in the radiator. These
cars don't have radiators. They don't have
oil systems.
These cars, like I said, have fewer moving
parts. They also have fewer systems involved.
So it's actually measuring the temperature
at the gas generator stage where the fuel
is being burned. So that would be quite high.
Again you'll notice the styling touch with
the aluminum fins up there by the front of
the center hump there. Again just-just the
aesthetic purpose.
And other than that it's a typical 1960's
Chrysler styling.
So the cars were lent out and what they did
is they said, "If you wanna borrow one of
these cars for three months [inaudible].
They got buried as you might imagine with
requests from people saying, "I want one."
So they went through all the people's names
that they got and they tried to scatter them
around the country, but they lent them out
to 203 different families over the period
of two years.
And what they would do is they'd pick some
family in Nebraska and they'd say, "Hey, you're
gonna get a car. Is that cool?" They'd check
'em up, make sure they don't have a criminal
record or something. And then they would call
the local press and have a big press event.
[audience chuckles]
And so a lot of times George Huebner would
show up; they'd toss the people the keys to
their new turbine car; and sometimes there
would just be a guy from-from Chrysler. And
it was often a guy named Bill Kerry, who's
this gentleman here. He's also the man on
the cover of the book.
And Bill Kerry's a fascinating guy. I interviewed
him for this book. And he was a technician
at Chrysler who came to Chrysler when he heard
that they were gonna start building turbines.
He'd worked in the military on turbine aircraft
technology on helicopters. And when he went
to Chrysler they said, "We've got just the
job for you. You're gonna be the main mechanic
on this fleet of cars." So when they built
the 55 cars and lent them out to the public,
Bill Kerry was the guy who was tasked with
going around, keeping the cars running, delivering
them to people, and then if they broke down
he got the phone call.
And he told me that occasionally he'd get
a phone call at 3 o'clock in the morning and
they'd say, "We just got a phone call from
one of the users down in Texas. The engine
just blew up." And he would literally hop
on a, on a plane, fly to Texas, swap the engine
out, and he'd try to do it as quickly as possible
to get the car back on the road again.
Now the cars that were involved in the program
logged over a million miles over the period
of a couple years. And statistically speaking
it was very, very successful. The cars were
very, very dependable. But even so he did
get these odd late night phone calls.
This is obviously a posed photograph though
were he's pointing at the engine just in case
people didn't know where it was and you have
a nice young 60's couple straight off a sitcom.
The man in the hat and the thick glasses and
the woman with her little babushka on who
are, who are probably just wishing the photographers
would go away so they could get the car and
drive it. But these were gigantic, big press
events.
And I also interviewed a lot of people who
got to borrow the cars.
And if you think about it, you get to borrow
a jet car for three months and Chrysler said,
"As long as you put gas it in or fuel of some
sort and give it back to us we'll pick up
all the rest." So they paid for the maintenance,
they paid for the insurance, and if you had
any problems they'd come out and fix it no-no
questions asked, no charge.
And so I got a lot of photographs from people
I talked to like this one. And here's a family
that drove their car cross country and it's
someplace near the Continental Divide and
they hopped up to take the picture.
And the amazing thing about the turbine engine,
along with the other stuff I told you, is
that you could go out on a, on a pitch, cold
day, as cold as you can make it, and hit the
starter and the car'll start instantly.
It does not have the problem with the thick
oil you have in a piston engine, there's much
less friction inside the engine so the cars
can start immediately. And because they got
their heat for the inside of the car off the-they
ran the exhaust gases through the-the heating
unit, you would have hot air instantly as
well. So the defrosters and the heat worked
instantly.
And for the engineers, turbine engines run
better with cold air because cold air is denser.
And so everyone I talked to who lived either
out West or drove them out West, they said,
"Yeah these things ran great in the mountains."
Which is lots of people have trouble with
piston engine cars driving through the mountains
because of the carburetors and so on.
So again, this is some people just drivin'
theirs cross country.
At the end of the program they rounded the
cars up and they were thinking about what
to do next. And they considered the idea about
mass producing jet powered cars. They thought
these cars were practical enough to do that.
The problem is that right at the late 1960's
three things happened. The problem smog became
very, very apparent in America and people
in America started complaining about smog
and, "We need to do something about smog especially
in California."
So the Environmental Protection Agency was
formed and they were given the task of doing
something to clean up the air and the first
thing they attacked was automobiles and tailpipe
emissions.
And the guys at Chrysler spent all their time
making the engines run more efficiently and
more bullet proof; they hadn't really thought
that much about emissions. So they couldn't
do anything about the emissions on that short
notice.
The other problem is that the OPEC oil embargo
hit in the late '60s early '70s where we actually
had a gas crisis in America. And the federal
government again stepped in and announced
CAFE standards which is the Corporate Average
Fuel Economy standards for all the cars that
one car company builds.
The turbine cars did not get good gas mileage.
It wasn't bad gas mileage, but it wasn't good.
And the problem was CAFE standards is that
the government announced is simply, "You guys
have gotta come out next year and have your
gas standards here, the next year here," and
it escalated up. And they hadn't been working
on that.
So while they were thinking about, "Could
we defeat these problems?" And there were
some engineers at Chrysler who thought they
could, Chrysler ran into financial trouble.
And we all know that Chrysler went bankrupt
last year. Well they actually almost went
bankrupt in the late 1960's, early 1970's.
And right while all those things were happening
the guys at the turbine program were saying,
"Yeah, but we can build these cars." And they
couldn't.
So this was the car that they were going to
put on the road. They actually toyed with
the idea about building 500 of these.
Now this right here is a Coronet. It's got
a turbine engine in it, but it's the only
one they built. They built one of these and
this has got the next generation engine past
the one I showed you, the cutout of.
So this right here was what the Chrysler engineers,
if you'd talk to them in 1966, if you'd ask
them, "Could you make a car right now to sell
to the public that would blend right in, perform
like-like a regular car, that the average
person could drive, that's just as dependable
or better, do you have one?" That's it right
there.
Unfortunately, the three things I just told
you about interfered.
The other strange thing about the whole program
is as I mentioned to you in the beginning
that the car was multi-fuel. The car would
literally run on anything that burned and
you could mix those fuels.
So let's suppose you've got a tank full of
kerosene and one day you're driving down the
road and you get low-low on fuel and you don't,
can't find kerosene, well you pull into a
station, you put diesel into it. You can't
find diesel you can put tequila in it. If
you can't find tequila, you can put Chanel
No. 5 in it. It's gonna be expensive, but
you can do it.
And at the time that they first started the
program in '53, they almost never even mentioned
that aspect of it. I mean I can find you press
releases where they go, "Turbine engine is
better. It's lighter; it's simpler; it weighs
less." And they wouldn't even mention the
fuel economy or the-the multi-fuel aspect
of it.
Later on as they were struggling with tail
piping standards and the CAFE standards, somebody
said, "Wait a second. This thing will burn
non-petroleum based fuels. We could run alcohol
that our farmers could make by growing corn
or growing grass. Maybe we should emphasize
that a little bit.
So Chrysler started emphasizing it. But again,
this is 1973. And this is a Plymouth Satellite
and in front this, that's a turbine engine
in that car there, in front of it is engine,
a-a fuel stand that's got six different fuels
on it. And it's got everything on there from
non-leaded gasoline to alcohol to a variety
of mixtures and so on.
And they do these demonstrations where they
would actually go up and fire the car up,
have it running and flip switch, switch, switch,
switch to show that it would flawlessly on
these different fuels.
But again, this is so late in the game that
it didn't have that much of an impact.
One of the guys I interviewed for the book
was a test driver who drove these things out
at the Chelsea Proving Grounds and he literally
put hundreds of hours just driving a turbine
car with this big laps and that big oval out
there.
And he told me that he did a couple laps out
there running vegetable oil. And he goes,
"Yeah," he goes, "it smelled like they were
baking cookies."
[laughter]
But imagine what the world would be like if
we were all driving cars that made it smell
like we were baking cookies?
So this is one of those things that I like
to point out; this is sheer irony. One of
the ugliest cars ever built in Detroit and
it's got a jet engine in it. That is an Aspen,
the sister car of the Volare. And again Chrysler
was, the engineers were still working on developing
the engine, making it better and better and
better.
The engine in this car was light years ahead
of the one that they'd loaned out to the public.
But, like I said, they couldn't make it run
clean enough; the-the fuel economy wasn't
good enough; and Chrysler was at this point
really teetering on bankruptcy so they couldn't
do it.
And one of the guys I talked to who was involved
in the program intimately, I said, "What would
it have taken you guys. Let's suppose that
Chrysler said, 'Let's pull the trigger. Let's
make these cars; mass produce 'em; put 'em
on the road.'" And he said, "You would have
had to build whole plants from the ground
up because they didn't have the infrastructure
to manufacture the internal parts of the jet
engine." And he said, That would have cost
us about a billion dollars in 1970." And they
didn't have a billion dollars.
So this car, in front of the helicopter, is
the last turbine car Chrysler built. That's
1978. And again, extremely advanced engine
in this car; extremely efficient; extremely
cutting edge.
But at this point they were, they knew the
program was winding down and Chrysler pulled
the plug on the program in 1978. So that you
had 25 years of development of this and then
[makes cutting sound]
and nothing. So that's the end of the program.
[Inaudible] at the end of the user program
there were 55 of the Ghia Turbine Cars out
there. Chrysler rounded them up and destroyed
46 of 'em. And this is very reminiscent of
the, "who killed the electric car, the EV1?
General Motors at the end of the program rounded
all cars up and destroyed them.
And I've spoken to the guys in the program
and said, "Why did they do that?" And all
the car companies are hesitant to let their
prototypes get put out in the world. Because
if you think about it right now when we think
of the turbine car program we think, "Oh,
this is a suite of cars, they look really
cool, they ran really nice."
If they let these cars get out to just average
people, you're driving your turbine car along
the engine explodes. You and I can't fix it.
So either now the car doesn't run or we rip
the engine out, we drop in a V8, now we have
a turbine engined body that's running a piston
engine and it starts diminishing the PR of
this car.
So they actually sent word out to museums
and said, "If you want one of these cars you
can have it." So they actually got six museums
who took 'em up on the offer. They shipped
the cars out and they destroyed all the rest.
And I've actually interviewed guys who were
there at the wrecking yard in Romulus when
they actually crushed and burned these cars.
And I had one guy tell me, he goes, he goes
"I was crying like a baby." I mean he'd worked
on these cars for years and now they're destroying
them.
There were people who wanted to buy the cars.
Chrysler was getting letters from people saying,
"I wanna buy one. I don't care what it costs,
I'll buy one." And Chrysler's going, "We can't
sell it. It's a prototype."
So this car right here is one of the survivors.
This photograph was taken in Fort Wayne, Michigan,
the Fort down by Detroit. And they have at
the Detroit Historical Society so many cars
they can't display them all at their museum.
And they were one of the people who took 'em
on the offer to accept one of these cars,
but they had not place to put it so they stuck
in their storage facility inside the bubble
here.
I got to get in to see it and photograph it
because I was trying to track down as many
of them as I could.
The Henry Ford Museum's got one. Chrysler
has one at their museum as well, Walter Chrysler
Museum up in Auburn Hills. There's one at
the Smithsonian. There's one at the St. Louis
Museum of Transportation. There's one at the
Petersen Museum in L.A. And then two of them
are privately owned, one of which is owned
by Jay Leno.
That's me to the left of Jay Leno, 50 pounds
ago. And people say, "Wow, Jay's shorter than
I thought." And I say, "No, no, I'm taller
than you thought."
[laughter]
But that's Jay's turbine car. He actually
bought that from Chrysler about a year ago
when he came into town to do his free shows
at the Palace for unemployed people.
And Chrysler had kept three cars for themselves.
The three cars they kept were identical because
all the cars were identical.
So Chry-Jay went over to Chrysler after he
did one of his shows and he was talkin' to
some of his friends over there and he said,
"You know you guys have got three of these
cars. Do you really need three?"
And I wasn't privy to the conversations, but
my understanding is that he talked them into
selling him one of the three cars. They know
he's a car guy; he'll take care of it; he's
not gonna blow it up and drop a Slant-6 engine
into it. He'll take care of it and he'll see
to it that it-it-it-it's good.
So he got the car and he brought it to California.
This photograph is in Jay Leno's garage. And
that's also what he calls the facility where
he has 105 cars, 95 motorcycles, a steam engine,
a bus, and a bunch of other crazy stuff. He
loves technology.
And about an hour after this photograph was
taken he took me for a ride in one of his
steam cars. He's got a collection of steam
cars. He's also got a collection of electric
cars.
And he is as nice as he seems on TV. It's
not an act. He's an honest to God nice guy.
And just as a side note, I'm actually doing
book signing with him day after tomorrow in
Burbank. I'm flying out and he's gonna sit
with me and sign books, which is a nice thing
for him to do.
But he let me drive the car. And that was
the cool thing is that I had talked to him
previously about that I had written this book
and he said, "Well, if you're ever in California,
I'll let you drive the car." So I got to California
as fast as I could.
And I go out there and we go out for a drive
and we're drivin' around Burbank and-and we
stop so we could take some pictures. And the
pictures I showed you earlier are up at the
parking lot we took that day.
And then we're walking back to the car and
I said, "You know Jay you did tell me I could,
I could drive it." And I thought he was gonna
say I just drive it in circles around the
parking lot which I would have been happy
to do so I could say I drove it.
He said, "Oh here you go," and tosses me the
keys and-and he let me drive it. And I said,
"Where we going?" He says, "Oh, go back to
the garage."
So I got to drive that car in traffic. And
of course I'm sittin' at a light thinking
to myself, "I'm gonna be the knucklehead who's
behind the wheel and we get rear-ended by
somebody and I'm gonna go down in history
as the guy who wrecked Jay Leno's turbine
car."
[laughter]
Didn't happen though; we got it back safely
as evidenced by the photograph.
So that's the story of the Chrysler Turbine
Car.
And then while I was out there I was talking
to Jay and I'd still hadn't found a publisher
for the book. And he said to me, he goes,
"Well if it'll help you sell the book I'll
write you a forward for the book." And he's
written forwards for other car books. And
I said, "I think it'll help."
[laughter]
And he agreed to write the forward for me
and that actually is what got me an agent
which got the book sold. And the book came
out a month ago and it's actually doing pretty
well so.
It's interesting because a lot of people are
familiar with the idea that there were turbine
cars on the road and some people even remember
that Chrysler did this. But they had no idea
how long the program lasted, 25 years, or
how many of these cars they'd built, 'cause
they built 55 of those cars right there.
And there was a period, there's a certain
generational thing when I do book signings
I can tell the older guys will go, "I remember
those cars." And the young people of course
went, "What you talkin' about?"
[laughter]
And it's because there was as time when you'd
see those cars everywhere. And they-they were
almost common place. And the fact that they
disappeared completely, and now people go
"I wonder whatever happened to those turbine
cars?"
So that's also why I wrote the book. So --
[pause]
Any questions?
Okay.
>>Female in audience: Talk to me about when
you went to see all the families that had
driven these. What were kind of the stories
that they had?
>>Steve Lehto: Oh, yeah. No, I had a couple
pictures in there of that, but you're right.
I actually, Chrysler put out a really nice
book at the end of the program like, like
a, I'm not sure what they did with it, but
they put together a-a-a synopsis of the program.
It said, because they had their PR people
go out and interview these people and-and
they-they collated all the data and they actually
gave us, I actually have a list of the names,
occupations, and ages of every single person
that had one of these cars; 203 people.
Now remember this back in 1964 or '63, '65.
So I had to go and try to track these people
down.
So what I actually did is I sorted them by
age and started from the youngest and went
up. And I actually found something, 'cause
think of about if you're 25 years old that
long ago, next thing you know a lot of these
guys are no longer with us.
But I tracked down maybe a dozen of them.
And the stories were universally the same.
They loved the car. Everywhere they went it
drew a crowd. They'd be driving to church
and people would be waving and following 'em
and like they-they drive someplace and people
would follow them to get out to talk to them.
People would park in front of their house
and others would come up and knock on the
door and say, "Hey, can I look at your car?"
Chrysler actually anticipated some of this
and interestingly enough, for 1963 you cannot
pop the hood in this car without getting inside
of it. You also cannot pop the trunk without
getting inside of it, even if you have the
keys.
Because back then even though cars you walk
up underneath the hood and just feel and pop
the hood with the thing underneath the hood.
They were so worried about looky-loos wanting
to come by everywhere you'd go it would be,
"Well, I wanna look underneath the hood."
So they made it that way 'cause they anticipated
it and sure enough that's what happened.
I actually spoke to some families who said
that by the end of the three months they were
almost getting sick of the attention. They
loved the car, but they couldn't go someplace
without causing a commotion.
And so I-I-I spoke to one family in particular
and they said that they'd park in their driveway
every single day during dinner time people
knocking on the door, "Hey can I see your
car? Can I see your, can I go for a ride in
your car?"
And sure enough you can't turn that down.
So you're givin' people rides everywhere givin'
people rides in the car.
That one family said they actually stuck it
in the garage and closed the door when they
wanted peace and quiet 'cause otherwise they
couldn't get any rest.
And one of the guys I interviewed for the
book was 16 at the time that his parents got
one of these cars. And Chrysler actually said,
"Hey, do we have a problem lettin' this kid
drive the car? I mean he's in the family.
He's got a license." They let him drive the
car. So a 16 year old boy for three months
is driving this car to and from school --
[laughter]
he's gonna drive it around and it's all downhill
from that point. I don't care what car you
get, when you turn 17 you got to drive a turbine
car.
[laughter]
And-and he told me he said, "It was, it was
the hugest deal," because he was the kid who
got to drive a jet car. But again, everywhere
you go it's causing a commotion.
One guy told me he said, he goes, "You couldn't
make a short trip in it. You couldn't like
hop in it and run to the store for a loaf
of bread and come back. It would turn into
an hour long trip because everywhere you'd
go people would say," "Hey, is that your car?"
"Hey, can I talk to you about the car?"
And it got to the point where you-you had
to do this.
When Chrysler was interviewing people about
the program they would, and I actually have
the question sheets they used, they were clearly
aiming at trying to find people who were outgoing
and would-wouldn't mind that kind of activity.
But also they'd asked you, "How often do you
drive your car? Where do you drive your car?"
And then, "Where do you park your car when
you're at work?"
And I talked to a guy who's a dentist in California
and he told me that he thinks he got the car
because his dentist office was right at a
major intersection. And he said, "Well I'd
have to park my car in front of my office."
And he wasn't sure if it was a good or bad
thing. He said the guy called him right back
and said, "Yeah, that's a good thing."
Because this-this turbine car's in front of
this doctor's office all day long and that
was getting the image out there.
One of the cars actually starred in a movie.
There's a movie called The Lively Set starring
James Darren and some other unknowns. And
if you see the movie like on some really bad
channel on cable, in the opening credits it's
like, "The Lively Set" in typical '60s as
an announcer going, "They raced! They loved!
They had a good time! They listened to rock
and roll music!"
And it goes, "Starring James Darren," whoever
the co-stars, "And the Chrysler Turbine Car."
And it's credited like it's an actor.
[laughter]
And it's kind of funny because these shots
in the movie where they-they do these close-ups
and-and do a back up in front of a blue screen.
Chrysler, that's the one thing Chrysler wouldn't
do is they wouldn't let Hollywood get their
hands on the car. So they actually sent the
car to Hollywood and said, "You can film it,
but the only guy that can drive it is a guy
named George Stetcher." And George Stecher
was a mechanic on the program.
So all the shots of the close up are in so
close you can see the guy sittin' in the wrong
car. The second they back up they always back
up far enough that you can't see it's actually
a Chrysler mechanic driving it, not James
Darren.
So IMDb calls the movie a "horrid piece of
trash." But
[laughter]
it's got some great car chase scenes in their
of a turbine car and some regular cars racing
around out in the desert which makes no sense
at all for an auto race. But
[laughter]
typical Hollywood it's, so like I said, the
car is credited like it's an actor. So that's
kinda cool.
[pause]
>>Male in audience: What's the performance
of that compared to a normal car? You think
a jet engine's gonna have a lot of horse power.
Is that, did they scale it way down so that
it wouldn't be kind of ridiculous?
>>Steve Lehto: It was scaled way down to fit
underneath the hood and it was also geared
so it would behave more like a normal car.
One of the most amazing innovations with this
car was that it has automatic transmission
in it. And it has a torque flick auto which
is a very, very common Chrysler transmission
from the era. And to put power from turbine
engine to the rear wheels they simply have
the turbine spinning and a wheel, a-a-a fan
blade, that's facing backwards and there's
nothing here and then there's another fan
blade that's attached to the input shaft of
the transmission. So there's air blowing over
this fan which drives the rear wheels in essence,
okay?
So what that did was it allowed them to basically
not worry about people tearing up clutches
of manual transmissions, but it also made
it much simpler for them to build.
The neat thing about that was is that the
car didn't accelerate really quickly because
they had it geared so that it would run better
at highway speeds. But if you really want,
back in the 60's people want to step on the
gas in the car, launch like a rocket.
So some automotive guys who test drove the
vehicles for auto magazines complained and
said, "Hey I drove this car and zero to 60
is like horrible."
Well it was horrible if you didn't know what
you're doin'.
And George Huebner read a review, I think
it was Motor Trend Magazine, where a guy said
the-the acceleration is horrible. I, it's
horrible. These cars will never sell because
of that.
And George Huebner challenged the guy to a
race. And he let the guy pick another Chrysler
product and he got in the turbine car and
he puts his foot on the brake and floors it.
[laughter]
And because of the way that there's-there's
no torque convertor in there, you can do that.
He winds it to 45,000 RPM. The guy says, "Go,"
and he takes his foot off the brake and goes
swoosh. The thing takes off like a rocket.
[laughter]
Now, but he didn't want people to know about
that because that's obviously not good for
the engine to do it too often. But the point
is that you could make them go fast. It was
a question of what they were building it for.
And the program was designed to actually have-have
a vehicle that anybody could drive without
having to think too much about it being different
than a typical car of the time.
So, one drawback the car does not have air
conditioning, because air conditioning is
a parasitic draw that you can't do much about.
Later versions of it they put the air conditioning
compressor on the power stage or on the-the
the alpha stage and could get around some
of that. But other than that it's fine.
[laughter]
Anything else?
>>Female Commentator: Any other questions?
Well, thanks again for coming in today. We're
honored to have you as always and we wish
you lots of success with the, with the book.
>>Steve Lehto: Thank you.
[applause]